é em 1999
é eu recebi é a proposta de emprego dos
meus sonhos
fui chamado pra editar a a edição
brasileira da revista national
geographic é pela editora abril e eu
levei mais ou menos sete segundos pra
aceitar a proposta
eu não eu não perguntei eu juro por deus
eu não perguntei quanto pagava e é e
falei sim eu quero sinners editor da
national geographic no brasil
eles achavam que eu seria é um bom é
editor porque eu tenho uma é é uma
qualidade e meio bicultural eu sou um
cara de humanas de eu sou americano
nasci e fui criado lá nos estados unidos
fiz faculdade lá mas eu sou tão de
humanos que eu fiz um intercâmbio aqui
na fifa e lanche
isso que é essa é do povo
dilma anos e aquele ano aqui na fifa e
lech mudou minha minha vida é passei a
amar o brasil passei a querer ficar aqui
eu voltaria muitas vezes depois eu
casaria aqui com uma brasileira é casei
com duas brasileiras não simultaneamente
é e em 99 depois de uma carreira é
baseado várias coisas que foram contados
aqui me ofereceram a national geographic
oferecer o national geographic porque a
national geographic no brasil e no mundo
fora dos estados unidos é a boa parte
dela maior parte dela a tradução ea
tradução da national geographic e
precisa ser de altíssimo nível e como eu
tenho essa essa qualidade e bicultural
eles achavam que eu seria um cara bom é
para orientar a tradição ea tradução
dava muito é
a tratava muito trabalho realmente
porque a outra coisa outro motivo que
eles achavam que seria boa dito é que os
americanos danesh no national geographic
americana são muito exigentes e eles já
tinham percebido isso nos traz é ao
discutir o contrato negociar o contrato
e eles lhe são de difícil trato de certa
forma é eles fizeram pelo menos em 1999
eo monte uma equipe é e pratarias e
revista essas nossas traduções eram
enviadas é seu mandava para os melhores
produtores do brasil
essas traduções eram enviados para
especialistas em língua portuguesa em
universidades americanas
depois voltavam cheios de críticas é e
eu precisava negociar todo esse processo
de manter a um nível da tradição muito
alta e eu que eu cara de humanas não
sabia era a a quantidade de ciência que
tem nada national geographic e vocês
podem achar isso engraçado mas nós
precisávamos traduzi é reportagens que
continham muitos nomes de muitas
espécies que não existe no brasil não
existe na língua portuguesa então nós
precisamos como lida com isso é cada
caso era um caso dava muito trabalho e
aí em 2004 chegou esta edição americana
do lado direito do do seu lado direito e
sobre aquecimento global
isso em setembro de 2004 e isto caiu
como uma bomba dentro da minha cabeça eu
não sei o que eu pensava do clima antes
disso eu sabia que teve uma época é
gelado eu sabia que tinha tido a idade
do gelo acho que por causa dos cartuchos
sabia que no tempo dos dinossauros era
muito quente e tal mas eu nunca tinha
pensado muito sobre mudanças climáticas
e aqui vieram 47 páginas em 2004
sobre a questão das mudanças climáticas
dizendo exatamente o que nós sabemos
hoje dizendo que o homem está aquecendo
a terra está sobretudo com a emissão de
gases de efeito estufa através da queima
de combustíveis fósseis
através de da criação de gado com muita
fluência e ea roto através de
deflorestamento enfim tudo que nós
sabemos hoje em 2004 era novidade pra
mim e é novidade pra mim equipe e era
muita coisa pra nossa cabeça então eu
como editor recorriam uma aqui uma
reportagem de arquivo e publiquei
pública que os 42 46 páginas sobre
aquecimento global mas com essa capa
aqui do lado e se esquece essa capa e
retrô se sabe que não está marcando o
tempo aqui nem vou falar uns 45 minutos
[Música]
[Risadas]
ok eu publiquei essa outra capa é porque
eu achava que essa capa que o globo o
homem era e nuno ia dar certo não ia ter
uma 1 um desempenho bom no mercado
brasileiro e eu acho que foi uma decisão
muito acertada se você lê a chamada
nossa em português alerta ecológico o
aquecimento global ameaça o planeta é de
uma ingenuidade é que hoje é
inacreditável mas nós estávamos lá na
redação todo mundo do povo do de humanos
estava lá perdendo a virgindade
e sendo apresentado para esse essa
questão apocalíptica e muito muito
preocupante e nós levamos muito a sério
e eu particularmente passei a a a
estudar e em 2006 e 2007 já é com mais
informações já mais confiante de essa
capa americana é com uma chamado o fim
do gelo que eu achei genial nem parece
fim fim de festa e tal fim do gelo se
entenderam a piada letal mas assim
vencemos em mim é eu estava já com muita
consciência depois de três anos de
estudo é muito convencido da importância
desse tema é e eu acho que eu esqueci de
dizer que é capa dolores arábia foi o
mesmo tu é sensacional vender não lembro
de números mas vendeu 25 por cento acima
da média enquanto esta capa que foi um
fracasso e doeu redondo assim vendeu 25
30 por cento abaixo da média ninguém
queria falar é de aquecimento global e
eu descobri como é difícil falar desse
tema eu saía ia encontrar meus amigos
nas festas e daí esse tema 12 como falar
de mudanças climáticas em festa e eu
falava e fala você sabia
você sabia que o terreno está aquecendo
já que seu 0,6 graus e nesse ritmo e e
por aí vai até que um amigo meu numa
festa falou pra mim
mateus não sei parece aqueles caras de
times square com aqueles cartaz assim
dizendo que o fim está próximo e isso
foi um choque gigantes kubra mim porque
a minha imagem era de um sofisticado e
de toda nesta de graphic não desse cara
do time square mas o pior é que esse meu
amigo tinha razão e da narrativa das
mudanças climáticas
era essa aqui e passei
a atentar a mim tenha muito em achar
soluções narrativas que basicamente
dizer como é que se fala dessa questão
tão importante para a humanidade
sim é estranha sem deixar às pessoas é
como se comunica isso né
aí outro amigo meu me disse mas matheus
como é que vocês sabe como é que nós
sabemos que a temperatura está
aumentando
se o nosso isso foi um historiador seu
historiador amigo meu se nós não
tínhamos assim não temperaturas é
escritas não temos documento a
documentação da temperatura
mais do que sei lá eu chuto 200 anos e
tal não queria ter razão e aí nessa
época eu tinha um chefe visionário que
me deu um orçamento muito bom e saímos e
fizemos através do planeta sustentável
esse gibi grande contando a história do
clima respondendo a pergunta do meu
amigo do meu amigo como é que sabe que a
terra está acontecendo está aquecendo
bom é isso só para mostrar aqui os caras
estão acertando nós estamos já em um
grau de de aquecimento e nós precisamos
ler e encarar esse problema é diferente
a absmse se vê nessas curvas o quanto
nós precisamos diminuir as emissões e e
de gases de efeito estufa ea algo é como
é das por cento ao ano em vez de
diminuir
nós estamos na melhor das hipóteses
deixando tudo igual e cada ano que passa
a situação fica mais
é preocupante é não é verdade que
ninguém está falando disso os cientistas
estão falando disso e falando muito se
sente se organizar no ipcc e junto com
os ambientalistas é nós eles conseguiram
passar conseguiram passar o o o acordo
de paris e três não é o suficiente diego
problema que me coloca é que nem todo
mundo se identifica como ambientalista e
nem todo mundo é capaz de acompanhar
esse tipo de raciocínio dos cientistas
também a pergunta fica com o é que nós
podemos falar é entre amigos na família
no almoço de domingo nas festas como a
que se consegue falar de mudanças
climáticas e daí eu quero eu acho que
uma das melhores dicas que eu posso dar
é da gente falar das coisas bacanas que
estão acontecendo por conta da das
mudanças climáticas numa delas é o
energia renovável está crescendo num
ritmo frenético e e essa é uma coisa que
vai nos trazer muitos benefícios e isso
é movido pelo pelo aquecimento global
movido pelas mudanças climáticas
os automóveis a combustão de gasolina e
disso estão sendo começando a ser
proibidos no mundo inteiro e isso vai
nos ajudar muito e cria oportunidades é
gigantescas como esta por exemplo de
fazer carne a partir de plantas esse
produto aqui eu já experimentei posso
garantir que é delicioso
é ótimo e é uma tentativa isso foi uma
reação a uma tentativa de enfrentar a
questão é de mudanças climáticas e o
maior é o santo padroeiro
as mudanças climáticas no mundo fora da
ciência pelo menos ao nosso irmão manske
que acho que todo mundo aqui conhece ele
é o dono da da tese e o que mais que
descobriu é que prova a tesa esse
automóvel que esse é um dos carros e dos
melhores carros dele e ele achou isso é
uma lição que eu acho que todos nós
precisamos aprender que é pra você falar
e ele quer fazer carros elétricos por
causa de mudanças climáticas porque
carros elétricos têm muito menos
emissões e esses carros fossem se a são
alimentados por energia solar como nesse
telhado também vendido por ele essa
bateria também pedido por ele
então é você vai ter uma emissão de
gases de efeito estufa muito é pequena e
esse jeito de falar com carros muito
sedutores e sexy
está dando certo ao ponto de uma coisa
muito interessante se você olhar lá no
canto de marca de quepe a tese ela hoje
vale mais que a general motors
isso é particularmente louco é se você
olhar quantos carros produzidos de amor
us 10 milhões enquanto produz até 76 mil
e no entanto as empresas vale a mesma
coisa isto é saber falar de mudanças
climáticas
isso é convencer as pessoas de que o
produto dele é o futuro e isso é tão
interessante é tão eficaz no caso do
domaske que outro dia uns meses atrás
teve um furacão no caribe que destruiu
uma ilha e o vitimar que acho que estava
nessa casa e passou para essa barraca
aqui do lado e mandou essa mensagem
pelo a 100º eu achei quando eu vi que
fosse feito nos não é possível isso isso
é marketing sei lá o que é isso então aí
que ele vai fazer com o carro nesse
lugar mesmo assim não não tem nem na
estrada mas e tal mas não era
ele estava pedindo é baterias e energia
solar e o mais louco é que deu certo e
isso passou para o mundo real eo ei lá
nós que o percebeu uma oportunidade é de
marketing vão falar mas também de ajudar
e ajudar em porto rico que a outra ilha
que que teve um impacto gigantesco e ele
começou a mandar energia é placas de
energia solar e baterias e já colocou
ontem uma um hospital de crianças
funcionando de novo é com essas doações
isso é só pra lembrar pra lá estão indo
às emissões é isso aqui que nós
precisamos para manter a temperatura
abaixo de 2 graus e o brasil que ontem
anunciou um aumento de emissões de 8
aponta 9 por cento poderia virar uma
imensa costa rica s
a pena será o desmatamento e recuperar
pastos degradados seria líder mundial
seria líder mundial nesta área é e teria
uma credibilidade gigantesco pra falar
desse assunto
e pra oportunidades meu mas nada disso
vai acontecer se a gente não falar desse
assunto
então é que quero terminar com essa
publicação que me inspirou para essa
fala que eu pensei como falar com
garotos em festas e isso é fácil difícil
é que vamos falar com garotos e festas
sobre mudanças climáticas
obrigado
[Aplausos]